avvicinati Alla bambola
lì c'è la fabbrica dei giocattoli
aiuto
la maledizione della bambola
Pokémon gioco
come potete vedere qua c'è questa
bambola che sembra in realtà un uomo
caduto con la faccia da bambino non
sembra neanche una bambola E infatti fa
ancora più paura per questo forse
dovremmo scappare da questa bambola ma
Mettetevi comodi lasciate un bel mi
piace e iniziamo subito un nuovo Escape
Room andiamo andiamo andiamo andiamo in
prima persona
prima persona vuol dire che il gioco lo
vediamo non con il personaggio da fuori
in terza persona ma vediamo proprio con
gli occhi del personaggio quindi siamo
ancora più immersi nella storia dice di
andare qua Ma tu dove sei Prendi il
pacco dall'esterno e mettilo nella tua
camera da letto
Aspetta non sto capendo Ecco Vitale è
arrivato Mi raccomando dobbiamo fare
sempre questa Escape Room perché questa
è una di quelle Escape Room paurose
quindi Dobbiamo aiutarci a vicenda
allora
prendi il pacchetto e mettilo nella tua
camera da letto Dopodiché Trova le
forbici e apri il pacchetto Eh sì
signore allora abbiamo preso abbiamo
preso le forbici e Dov'è il pacchetto
Però qual è la camera eh eh eh
no Prima stavo mettendo il pacchettino
nella camera da letto Ecco qua ho messo
le polveri le forbici sono le forbici
sono qui proprio all'entrata qui le vedi
Eccole sono qui guarda Rita Ah ok ok
Eccole qua cosa ci sarà dentro in questo
pacchetto
l'ho appena scoperto No la bambola
maledetta sembra amichevole Guarda
facciamo Quella manina Ciao
avvicinati
Esatto Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh dove dentro una
scatola
cliccando sopra forse perché noi
l'abbiamo rinchiuso dentro una scatola e
luce di luce arricchite nelle Escape
Room
Ok abbiamo rotto il muro Guarda Sì sì
anche altri sono intrappolati dalla
bambola anche questo muro maledetta come
noi e adesso un altro muro Ma quanti
muri ci sono Infatti vuole assicurarsi
che non scappiamo Ma noi riusciremo a
scappare e torneremo dalla bambola che
figo Wow
Premi il bottone sulla roccia rossa per
sbloccare Le piattaforme quale roccia
Rossa forse qua c'è la freccia Quindi
immagino che siamo finora mi piace un
sacco questo Escape Room alla fine del
video come sempre scriveteci il vostro
voto da 1 a 10
che è successo
che è un tempio si sono alzate delle
pietre per farci passare quindi si è
aperto un passaggio
Allora
però non ti vedo Dove sei Sono qui
dietro di te Ah eccoti sei molto
luminoso non so che è successo qua c'è
una statua con la faccia della bambola
maledetta Che brutto Chi l'avrà
costruita quella statua e qua c'è
scritto Pericolo di morte Cioè non c'è
scritto cioè c'è il tempio Quindi
immagino che sia Pericolo di morte sì
sia molto chiaro
trova il lancia Tre Sfere Verdi lungo la
rampa per aprire il portale qua c'è una
sfera verde credo No figo qua ce n'è una
Sì Eccone una qua dove la devo lanciare
non mi ricordo non ho capito forse qua
per aprire il portale e mi sa che ho
sbagliato È caduta laggiù la sfera ma
non è successo niente
cosa succederà ok rigeneriamo
ok Questo questo qua sotto Sì dobbiamo
lanciarle qua in questi buchi qua Ah non
l'avevo capito
Ce l'hai fatta sì no no una ha colpito
lì credo Credo
ora Ne manca un'altra devo rigenerare
ancora le palline qui perché hai
sbagliato Sì mi è caduta eh eh credo che
stia funzionando forse me ne manca solo
una Vediamo se funziona
Se siete riuscito Eh no Ancora nemmeno
una e tu Ma come era una invece ha messo
due a zero dai È facilissimo basta
mettermi qua Ok ci provo eh Prova ok
una è andata
cosa sta succedendo Non lo so Anita
è successo qualcosa ma devo andare lì
verso la statua del bambola maledetta
c'è un portale qua Dai sbrigati Vitale
c'è un portale Eccomi sto arrivando
perché siamo così luminosi che cosa
succede dobbiamo andare dentro a questo
portale Arrivo arrivo
[Musica]
ma siamo dentro un laboratorio E cosa
c'entra con il tempio maledetto Provo il
pulsante premilo per aprire la porta di
ventilazione piano ho capito qua fanno
gli esperimenti Guardate
come esperimenti quindi probabilmente
qualcuno ha creato la bambola forse
qualche scienziato Guarda qualcosa che
pietra la pietra quella lì che abbiamo
visto nel tempio No che c'entra
Uh questo è pagato tutto oh no si sta
allagando tutto Sì quindi dobbiamo super
sbrigarci adesso questi finiremo
elettrizzati oppure sfracellati come
evitare là sotto così notare Ho fatto un
salto
Aspetta ma cosa devo trovare quindi non
mi ricordo dei pulsanti aspetta
Aspetta ho trovato qualcosa Allora
dobbiamo salire qua sopra Vedi c'è la
freccia andiamo Seguimi seguimi che non
ho capito dove andare ok mi fido
Ah per non passare nell'acqua solo
bravissimo
Per un pelo Riprova quasi
Ok proviamo a premere il pulsante sei
riuscita
Sì ho premuto il pulsante ma non è
successo niente
Sì Allora dobbiamo salire là sopra io lo
vedo ancora vedo ancora che c'è il
lucchetto Perché io ancora non l'ho
premuto non so come si fa a salire la
risposta ti devo passare
No no
per farti passare Mi sono sfracellata
Allora premiamo il bottone il bottone
come facciamo a salire però
o no Ha preso tutto fuoco Sì ha
funzionato allora penso di sapere come
si fa Come si fa Allora dobbiamo tornare
tutti
indietro Ok Ah no aspetta Forse dobbiamo
salire da qua da dove vedi qua c'è un
palo e poi qua sopra
non sono caduta ancora non so come e poi
pianissimo
non scivolare qua mi raccomando ci provo
Ecco Vitale ce la farà Sì finora ce l'ha
fatta No
non scivolare Ok
questi questi tubi così messi tutti male
altrimenti spariti la bambola maledetta
Immagino perché questa è il mio
laboratorio
[Musica]
che sto dritto strano è stato facile Ehi
dove siamo guardati c'è un sole con la
faccia della bambola maledetta una casa
in miniatura in cui c'è scritto
giocattoli e delle candele secondo me
c'è una storia dietro questa bambola
maledetta forse prima la vendevano in
questo negozio di giocattoli e poi è
successo qualcosa
eliminare tutti quanti Sì infatti c'è
rinchiuso qua dentro dove siamo caduti
c'è una freccia è un bottone un garage
Cosa
uscirà oh oh oh oh aiuto aiuto aiuto
Perché povera festa così Aiutatemi mi ha
preso Non so se è più Inquietante il
fatto che sembri un uomo con i baffi ho
paura che muovono la testa così allora
aspetta dobbiamo cercare una tecnica
quindi una volta aperto Dobbiamo provare
a scappare in qualche modo ti dico io
qual è la tecnica scappare e basta Mamma
mia Che brutta
eh ok sto scappando sto scappando siamo
nel negozio di giocattoli Vedi c'è
scritto Toys
sono riuscito
Mamma mia è vicinissima Mamma mia sto
seguendo è un labirinto Io sto solo
correndo di più possibile wow no ti ha
preso
io Forse ce l'ho fatta davvero
laggiù è scomparso devi correre
velocissimo devo prendere in fondo e poi
e anche se arriva poi tu sai sulla scala
nel contesto di areazione non può più
prenderti
sopra stai sopra così poco ha preso ma
stavi salendo le scale e non ho fatto in
tempo lasciate un mi piace per portare
fortuna abitare tutto
entro cinque secondi cinque quattro Tre
due uno a tempo scaduto ci siete
riusciti soprattutto a scappare Non
funzionerà il vostro mi piace vediamo
Vediamo se ce la farà Vitale Dov'è la
scala dai sali sopra
mi piace Ha funzionato ti porta sempre
fortunata qui trova la valvola rossa e
Spegnila Dopodiché trova e premi il
pulsante sali Ok dobbiamo trovare la
valvola rossa sono troppi guarda
eh Anita io non ti vedo più male no mi
sono sfracellato in questa stanza e devo
provare a salire qua sopra Ah ho capito
Ok Prova a mettere tutto uno sopra
l'altro e poi metto anche questa sedia
qua sopra e chi è che mi sta buttando
giù la sedia Io non riesco a capire che
cosa stai facendo Sto cercando di salire
sopra Vedi Sono sopra la sedia ce l'ho
fatta Ho trovato la valvola rossa e l'ho
girata Era questa la valvola Dai prova a
salire su Subito
Allora devi mettere due scatole e poi la
sedia una sopra l'altra Sì così poi
riesci a salire da sopra ci provo Ecco
Vitale che trasporta anche visibili
perché non ci riesco mi cadono sempre ci
provo eh Dai sali sopra ma Oh come
perché mi fa cadere tutto perché devi
salire anche sulla sedia
[Musica]
Ok Ora che abbiamo premuto la valvola
possiamo continuare qua Ma dici dopo la
parte e qua c'è un pulsante rosso
premiamo il pulsante vediamo che è
successo
Immagino che se sarà sbloccato qualcosa
Ecco qua c'è una
Ma come hai fatto a spregelare Uffa
Prima devo riuscire a passare qua dai
E poi Qua sembra strano ma è difficile
questa Escape Room soprattutto in prima
persona Ok perfetto saliamo e adesso
trova e tira due leve per aprire la
porta vai alla stanza 1 per trovare la
prima leva Allora facciamo come tira due
leve devo dobbiamo prima trovare due
leve Qua c'è un pulsante però Servirà
qualcosa
Sì Ah guarda ho capito dobbiamo prendere
i pacchi per salire su in alto guardate
questa stanza e fa paura Sì c'è la
faccia della bambola cattiva qua Ok
proviamo a salire là sopra portiamo i
pacchi
Ok ora dovrei riuscire a saltare qua
sopra sì ecco adesso c'è tutto un
labirinto da fare qua sopra Wow È
fighissimo questa stanza tutta nera con
le stelle Peccato che c'è la bambola
cattiva No sono caduto giù di nuovo
Anche io dovrei fare tutto da capo ci
sono quasi mi mancano tipo 150
mattonelle ancora
ma basta perché cazzo stai sempre lì Ok
mi metto in terza persona solo per
superare questo stage altrimenti non ce
la faccio non riesco a capire la
distanza Molto bene molto bene Ho
trovato la prima leva Eccola qua la leva
prendiamo la leva
Ok Ora che ho premuto la leva posso
tornare in prima persona e via brava
la seconda leva sarà Qua c'è scritto
prendi questo bottone giocattoli
fattoria no no fattoria Ah ah ah Come si
dice in italiano non mi ricordo bene i
giocattoli
Eh ma dove sarà Guarda qua c'è una culla
probabilmente la bambola bambino
malefico dormiva qua dentro questa è la
sua stanza dobbiamo trovare qualcosa per
andare là sopra Uh guarda il cuscino fa
saltare fighissimo
e ora dobbiamo appenderci a questa corda
calare qua sopra di nuovo il cuscino
Figo super divertente con questa
divertente ma facile cadere giù e ora ci
vuole la terza persona altrimenti non ci
riesco
Sì
in terza persona non ci crederai ma sono
riuscito a saltare sulla corda per me è
tanto già Poi c'è un'altra cuscino
ancora un'altra corda devo dire che
l'hanno fatta No un po' complicata
queste Escape Room però è super
divertente
voltato l'altra leva torniamo in prima
persona uscita Sì è facile ora Voglio
ascoltare pochissimo Guarda che figo
Saltare su queste cose qua c'è un
pulsante
No è chiusa Ah c'è un lucchetto Ma si
apre lo stesso davvero
non voglio affrontare la bambola
Malefica da sola non ce la faccio
passare questo livello trova la chiave
nascosta all'interno di una delle
scatole dell'ufficio Dopodiché sblocca
la porta con il cartello Exit Guardate
lì c'è la fabbrica dei giocattoli
esploriamo quest'area Allora qua c'è
un'altra porta ma è chiusa
vediamo qua
questa è aperta la porta ci sono varie
scatole cosa ci saranno
solo un passo dalla seconda leva non
dirlo perché così Vuol dire che cadi
meglio non dire niente invece ci sono
riuscito Ciao
apriamo il bottone
sto facendo scomparire le scatole quindi
vuol dire che devo cercare in tutte le
scatole se c'è qualcosa di nascosto
Wow trova la chiave nascosta all'interno
di una delle scatole dell'ufficio dove
Chi è sblocca la porta con il cartello
Exit la chiave sarà in una di queste
scatole Eccolo Ora voglio rompere anche
le altre scatole per vedere se c'è
qualcos'altro no ho preso la chiave
era là dietro quindi la chiave Sì ok Non
ci resta che aprire la porta No questa è
la chiesa Ehi Apriti in scatola
praticamente stiamo rompendo le scatole
Sì ti rendi conto è quello che vi piace
fare
Apriamo la porta
cosa è successo ci sono degli schizzi di
sangue nella parete Il che vuol dire che
probabilmente la bambola È qua vicino
aspetta Aiuto
No vabbè non mi ricordo che mi sta
facendo seguendo pensavo fosse solo il
video del gioco No
che brutta brutta aiuto scappa scappa
scappa scappa
[Musica]
bambola Io sto provando a scappare al
contrario non funziona
con le macchie di sangue sono delle
frecce
No pensavo solo fossero solo le sue
vittime Io non capisco
se segui le frecce Mi sa che devi
trovare prima o poi un'uscita una devi
scegliere una porta praticamente perché
altrimenti è tutto uguale E certo che
devi scegliere una porta
chiusa no
OK riproviamo questa volta non mi
fermerò non ci credo l'ho trovata quindi
devi solo andare avanti Sì velocissimo
eh senza aprire nessuna pagina
e ho detto proviamo vai vai vai vai
corri corri corri corri corri corri
corri corri
credo che sia vicino più o meno vicino
spero per te vai vai vai vai vai
continua continua eh Mamma mia che
brutto dai via ti manca poco poco io non
ti girare Non ti girare
ce la farò Vai vai Bravo bravo sono qui
prova in ritardo
come muoveva la testa andiamo Qui
queste Escape Room fa venire un po' di
ansia e di quelle Escape Room paurose
Però finora molto divertente come ho
fatto Son caduto ma non mi sono
sfracellato ed è assurdo
strano cioè sarà stato un bug
e adesso Comunque è molto diversa dalle
altre
a delle aree super diverse non mi dire
che torna Adesso
no Sei contento adoro super velocità Ok
vediamo
via
che figo che figo ancora super velocità
vorrei avere sempre la super velocità
quando scappo dai cattivi
E ora dove stiamo andando sembra una
prigione questa Che bello però stiamo
saltando velocissimamente su tutti i
punti quasi tutte Oh oh C'è mancato poco
attento Qua ci sono delle trappole
invece Ok andiamo ancora alla velocità
Sì siamo riusciti a scappare ma non
stiamo ancora riusciti a scappare del
tutto è finita la super velocità e
adesso
cos'è questo inquietante questa parte ci
sono anche dei rumori strani o sbaglio
ne vedo qualcosa che non ti piacerà Che
cosa hai laser No peggio la bambola la
vedi è lì che brutto sta dormendo però
proviamo a Non svegliarlo anche se sono
sicura che si sveglierà Però proviamo a
Non svegliarlo fermiamo il bottone
Ho già capito cosa dobbiamo fare questa
è la sfida finale dobbiamo stare No no
tipo
dei tuoni hai visto
ma soprattutto perché non lo stiamo
colpendo Tu sei riuscita a colpirlo
ogni tanto
uffa
riproviamo questa volta ce la farò a
eliminarti bambola Malefica con i baffi
Allora Tocca saltare quando lui manda
quella Honda energetica Se ci riusciamo
aiuto
Però lui continua a lanciare ci sono
anche degli spuntoni visto anche gli
spuntoni
Rossi Ah ah ah sei morto No ancora no
però ci manca poco sono rosso Io l'avevo
quasi sconfitto
Uffa
Ehi vai via
no ce l'ho fatta davvero fatta
devo scappare però perché continuano ad
apparire di spuntoni vedete è come tale
che sta combattendo contro il nemico
invisibile
lanciamo un raso Vitale eh manca poco
manca poco 500 250 Wow ce l'ho fatta non
lo so se ce l'ho fatta non lo so non lo
so Hahaha
ce l'ho fatta dai scappa subito qua nel
garage Ci siamo registrati bene
misteriosa bibita dice Non capisco quale
bibita non ce l'hai finita qua si è
buggato Stiamo uscendo dalla fabbrica
dei giocattoli dove c'era la bambola
vedi Ok adesso dove andiamo c'è un
pulmino qua che ci aspetta
apposta per farci scappare
Non capivo siamo nel pulmino
Beach dei vincitori
dove ci porta
Eh devi toglierti dalla strada Se no ti
spiaccica Chi era prima Ti ho visto
nella strada
completata Allora io gli do un otto e
mezzo e tu io gli do un bel 9 perché
comunque era difficile ma bella e mi è
piaciuto un sacco sì Aspetta guarda
siamo in un'altra area voi Che voto gli
date scrivetelo nei commenti queste sono
altre Escape Room super paurose Guarda
lasciate mi piace se volete che proviamo
un'altra di queste Escape Room paurose E
ora vi lasciamo Qua quattro roselline su
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
eh Buona visione Ciao